guardian angels powerless
as suddenly christmas is cancelled for
millions
and today was made the last shopping day
of advent
by government it was exactly what this
man didn't want to have to do
we must i'm afraid look again at
christmas and
as prime minister it's my duty to take
difficult decisions
to do what is right to protect the
people
of this country we will introduce new
restrictions
in the most affected areas specifically
those parts of london
the south east and the east of england
which are currently
in tier three these areas
will enter a new tier 4 which will be
broadly equivalent to the
national restrictions which were in
place in england in november
that means residents in those areas must
stay at home apart from limited
exemptions set out in law
non-essential retail indoor gyms and
leisure facilities and
personal care services must close
people must work from home if they can
but may travel to work if this is not
possible for example in the
construction and manufacturing sectors
people should not enter or leave tier 4
areas and tier 4 residents
must not stay overnight away from home
in england those living in tier 4 areas
should not mix
with anyone outside their own household
at christmas
though support bubbles will remain in
place
for those of particular risk of
loneliness or isolation
across the rest of the country the
christmas rules allowing up to three
households to meet
will now be limited to christmas day
only
rather than the five days as previously
set out
i know how disappointing this will be i
know
how much emotion people invest in this
time of year and how important
it is for instance for grandparents to
see
their grandchildren for families to be
together when the science
changes we must change our response
when the virus changes its method of
attack
we must change our method of
defense and as your prime minister i
sincerely believe there is no
alternative open to me
without action the evidence suggests
that infections would soar
hospitals would become overwhelmed and
many thousands more would lose their
lives
he only found out about a new strain
sweeping the south and east last weekend
one week later and it has forced a
complete rewrite of coronavirus policy
it seems that the spread is now being
driven by the new variant of the virus
there's no evidence that it causes more
severe illness
or higher mortality but it does appear
to be passed on significantly more
easily
although there's considerable
uncertainty it may be up to 70 percent
more transmissible than the old
variant the original version of the
disease
this is causing the virus to accelerate
transmission across the south and east
of england
in the southeast 43 percent of the virus
is now
this new variant uh in the east of
england it's 59
and in london 62 the numbers may vary
slightly but those numbers are broadly
right and
those have gone up very very fast
over the last few weeks viruses mutate
all the time but the new variant
contains
23 different changes
many of them associated with changes in
the protein that the virus makes
this is an unusually large number of
variants
it's also got variants in areas of the
virus
that are known to be associated with how
the virus binds to cells and
enters cells so there are some changes
which cause concern in terms of how the
virus looks
the government is just starting to work
out the full
impact this decision will be upsetting
for millions of people so can you just
speak directly to everyone suddenly now
spending christmas day alone what hope
can you give them
i suppose the message is you know that
this is the year to lift a glass to
to those who aren't there in the
knowledge that it's in it's precisely
because they aren't there to celebrate
christmas with you
this year that uh we all have a better
chance
that they'll be there next year to
celebrate christmas with you
i suppose that would be my my message
sam uh to the country
is the new strain impervious to social
distancing measures might the
two meter rule and existing face
coverings no longer be enough to protect
people
we do not think that the current
measures will not work against this
but we're going to have to do a lot more
more
in a sense the stand cell it's like you
were cycling up a steep hill and now
you've got the wind against you as well
you just have to do that much more to
actually keep going
we of course bitterly i regret the the
changes that are that are necessary but
alas when the facts change uh you have
to change your approach
you could tell from boris johnson's
demeanor that he knows
just how badly this will go down with
the country
he didn't try and empathize with the
nation or articulate its distress
he just looked wounded and winded at a
decision he's tried so long to fight
but now he needs the country to comply
with his instructions
the lights of the capital still sparkle
but the joy beneath isn't there tonight
sam coates sky news